[Music]
the hell I just noticed something we
have an empty seat in our audience
tonight there's an empty seat I can't I
can't believe it I I don't think we've
ever had an empty seat before you know
i-i've been doing this almost 20 years
I've never seen an empty seat I can only
do a show in front of a full audience
how did it happen I don't know how it
happens right take care all right all
right you just stay here you keep them
busy I'll take care of it will do
something hurry
[Music]
[Music]
go go drive just drive turn them here
the traffic is killing us drive like
your life depends on it
lose the horn
you can see use the siren out of the way
Queenie we don't have a siren
and it's so important to pay attention
to your responsibilities because it
comes from you absolutely have to sorry
what are you doing we're in the middle
of this you know I just gotta borrow
something real quick
could you come with me please thank you
go back to fixing their problems
[Music]
[Applause]
okay just right here
thank you
it's okay
[Music]
we've got a great show tonight from the
hit CBS series The Big Bang Theory Simon
Helberg
from the new film the end of watching
pitch-perfect Anna Kendrick is here
here's a guest filter a
we got a great show coming up fully
right back
[Applause]